nous sommes dit que dans le finistère au
pouldu
c'est un pays riche 20 30 vaches
déployer bien remplie des prairies
vertes et le soleil par dessus tout
[Musique]
c'est mon ami monsieur martin avec des
gens comme lui on devient très facile
mon ami
à condition bien sûr de savoir voir les
choses d'une certaine façon confrères
des colporteurs porteurs d'histoires de
nouvelles intelligent par profession
toujours lentement et dont tout à
l'heure le nom avec le terme il y avait
des débats oui c'est une vieille
tradition c'est trop tard mais des
policiers vous n'habitez pas non je suis
n 1 bat atteindrait environ première est
que ces méthodes deux jours deux jours
vous ne savez par contre c'est quoi
[Musique]
ainsi pour céder à vivre il fallait
franchir la montagne sortir de la pub
est allé vers les riches terres de saint
pol de leon nord ou de châteaulin au sud
ou dans la mer vers crozon vers
concarneau lorient
aujourd'hui mon ami monsieur martin mise
à part avec sa charrette
on ne franchit la montagne peut
définitivement ou comme cette crèche
qu'avec d'autres dernier power pour la
journée entamée net plutôt que d'avoir
des trous d'eau
la jeune génération c'est-à-dire deux
enfants mais ne sont plus du métier du
préfet franchement paris alors un métier
qui serait spécialisé
même tout en étant bon bruit csii a
séduit tant en huit ans le petit patron
mais se fit lower qui disparaît restait
l'un des personnages légendaires de
cette bretagne de l'intérieur il a sa
chanson de geste qui porte son nom et
qu'il présente comme le personnage
pittoresque bohème ils étaient
fatalement de par sa vie errante et
aussi comme un mauvais garnement car on
a beau temps à mes dires des petits
revient de loin
[Musique]
c'est à dire mon père marié sénia basile
ok on va donner dans un communiqué il
aimait à la métairie tout la leyre c'est
à dire le nom de la paire bazaille
handicap hard on you babe l'aide à des
mets aux dalles des prêts d'aller mais
au talent d'herbe doit d'encolure ago
locaux
dans dix points en mai contre aucun des
stocks bas débit au prix plein fouet et
mazamet gouband est ou pas bio alors que
j'en ai c'est le petit gens qu'on
appelait quand il va au pardon à chaque
foyer sous peu mais on a tout perdu
il a failli perdre sa culotte le jour à
locker le pauvre malheureux
oui c'était comme ça mais le prépresse
et la capitale tripoli
si ironique l'avenant de son nom de
famille 74 ans chante avec autant de
sincérité de couleur chansons depuis le
web c'est qu'il habite depuis toujours à
saint-herblain à sept kilomètres de ses
locaux fret capitale des chiffonniers au
pied de l'église immense pour ce tout
petit pays avec finn sa femme ils
forment depuis 45 ans un merveilleux de
coupe et de mortalité
et puis on a continué il ya encore
beaucoup de jeunes dans tes mains moines
beaucoup moins puisqu'ils sont
obligatoires pourquoi parce les airs
maintenant par ici sont bien sortis tout
en l1 à perm a été trop pris seulement
non content des deux zones avec oui ce
n'est pas connecté on était heureux si
heureux le vois bien entendu
maniche nom de l'artiste
il s'enrichit sans vent le dos le dos
rond pour bien faire est restée près de
10 heures sur deûle à les couvrir la wii
ne savent pas où ils vont ils ont plein
de métiers panon certainement téléphone
avec un pas en avant pour un mécanicien
durand maire de mansle à la menthe à
aubin au dessus bien sûr certainement
vous l'entendiez que chantait pas mais
dans le mode genève tout le monde savait
chanter dans les environs et nous sommes
à la limite 3 ans et pleyben une voix
châteauneuf et alors vous pensez que sur
l'âge sur la place là c'est à dire de
notre édifice là on a donc je dégage de
l'ensemble
et vous pensez qu'il y avait entre les
chanteurs de pluie de l'eau qu'est prête
de colo rectaux les ul voix des
compagnies à bas un peu d'animosité
aussi de très vifs avec ça donne et ses
chansons chanson là c'était pour un
gabon c'était sur un air de gavottes
tout le temps j'avais une journée de
matane une journée de fenaison une laure
et le royal de points arrachés les
pommes de terre et joseph mayo kani bé
oui avec proposé à huy et on reste et
vous pensez à fait dans la nuit pour
remettre sa vraie lendemain matin quand
même et on buvait du cinoche de saint
avold et à tourner à rio les charrues
vous pensez à l'entente les férus
agraire la veille et il fallait être
costaud pour savourer dans un élan où il
y avait les souches dans le temps il y
avait des touts petites herm on se
contenter d'un champ 2
et puis une ou deux ans ce pur vite elle
attend et on fait des émules
quand vous êtes vous connu quand vous
vous mariez ce que vous êtes marié connu
pendant une gavotte tout bien trop
aujourd'hui ce que nous sommes moi
j'aime bien moi j'ai toujours été ici
j'ai invité alain vila et ville et
inviter aux voix
c'est à lui de les faire des commissions
à intermot et puis on est oui seulement
elle avait des cinq ans de mouvement
il avait juste monté amidon et il est
venu de son gamin j'étais contente
d'être un bébé c'est à dire mais comme
tout le monde mais je me suis mariée
avec un problème surtout la guerre et la
paix et aussi parce qu'il y en est resté
beaucoup
alors vous pensez bien après la
manoeuvre tout ça et puis à beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont ces sens marié après
donc parler de la gavotte tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que c'est comme dans ce
programme at all à la gavotte c'était
une autre ne principal nantes parce que
nous regrettions bas aucune autre vérité
tout de suite montré un peu trop bas on
pourrait bien faire le phare de la gamme
à ses voeux le premier jeu vidéo mario
wii
[Musique]
herriot mise à la poubelle quand vous
dansez savourer ça longtemps avait une
demi-heure - au moins il avait raison
salut salut au delà même des défendeurs
et vous donner tout ce que vous avez
perdu ma wii
[Musique]